همم الحمله الانتخابيه تنطلقت داخل ان شاء
الله يوم 25 نوفمبر وتنتهي يوم 15 ديسمبر
الاستعدادات حديثه لانجاح هذه المرحله من
المسار الانتخابي همم نحن اليوم نقوم
بملتقيات بدات بالعاصمه همم اليوم اليوم
قمنا بملتقاء
وغدا ان شاء الله سينطلق
في مدينه جيبسوس
الملتقيات هديه هي بين الهيئه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات والهيئات الفرعيه
والمترشحين لعضويه مجلس النواب وكذلك
المجتمع المجتمع المدني موضوع الملتقيات
التي تم اجرائها والتي سيجرى غدا هي
المسائل القانونيه والتقنيه والفنيه التي
من الممكن شرحها خلال
مده همم
الحمله الانتخابيه في الحقيقه الملتقيات
كانت مثمره جدا في لقاء تونس والقيروان
ونتوقع ان تكون كذلك مثمره في لقاء غدا في
مدينه
همم المسائل كما قلت هي مساء القانونيه
والفنيه والاستعدادات الماديه واللوجستيه
والقواعد العامه التي تحكم او سعوديه
وفيما يتعلق تقريبا حمله ان انتخابيه وفي
الرقابه على الحمله الانتخابات
طيب سيد ماهر الجديده بالحديث عن الرقابه
تتحدث عن المتابعه الاعلاميه لهاته الحمله
الهيئه العليا للاتصال السمع البصري تتهم
هيئه الانتخابات بالاستحواذ على صلاحياتها
وتقاضيها امام القضاء الاداري لماذا كل
ذلك شكرا
العلاقه بين الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات والهيئه العليا المستقله
للاعلام السمعي البصري هي علاقه تنظيميه
يحكمها القانون كان من المفترض ان يستر
قرار مشتركا عن عن الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات والهيئه العليا المستقله
للسمعي البصري ولكن هذا القرار لم يصدر
على اعتبار ان لم تتلقى مشروع قرار مشترك
من طرف الهيئه العليا اللي سامعي البصري
تراسلنا الهيئه العليا للسمعي البصري
بضروره مدنا بمشروع القرار ثم نبهنا عليها
في مناسبه ثانيه لم نتوصل بمشروع القرار
الهيئه من باب من بحكم القانون وبحكم
الدستور لها ولايه عامه على تنظيم
الانتخابات ولها مسؤوليه وطنيه من اجل
انجاح المسار الانتخابي اذا كان الهيئه
العليا للاتصال السمعي البصري لم تمكننا
من المشروع القرار فان مسار الانتخابات لم
يتوقف بل ستستمر وستتحمل كل الهيئه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات
المسؤوليه الوطنيه لانجاح المسار
الانتخابي على كل حال اذا كان الهيئه
العليا المستقله للسمع البصري تريد ان
تقاضي الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات
فهذا حقها حقه مقفول للدستور وان الجهه
القضائيه الوحيد اذا التي تبث في هذه
المساله هي المحكمه الاداريه
اتصل اتصل
من هنا وهناك هذا غير مجالها المجال اليوم
القضاء الاداري هو الذي سياتم المساله ان
توصلنا هو وسيكون للهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات الرد
القانوني على اذا كان اذا كان هناك طعم
سنتولى الرد على الطعن هذا امام المحكمه
الاداريه السيد ماهر الجديده باختصار شديد
لو سمحت اذا ذهبنا الوقت هل فعلا هيئه
الانتخابات لوحه من خلال قرارها برفع
الخروقات التي ترتكب اثناء الحمله
الانتخابيه الى النيابه العموميه في ما
اعتبره البعض ترهيبا بوسائل الاعلام
باختصار شديد لو سمحت
شكرا هو كما تعلمون المخالفات الانتخابيه
يمكن ان نصنفها مخالفات بسيطه لا يمكن ان
تؤثر على وجه الفصل في المساره العمليه
الانتخابيه وبالتالي لا يمكن ان تؤثر ولا
يمكن اعتمادها كاحدد لنتائج الانتخابات
ولكن هذه المخالفات يمكن ان تكون ان تصنف
جرائم جرائ
م القانون الجزائري وبالتالي فان الجهه
الوحيده التي يمكن ان تعاقب المخالفات هذه
هي الجهه القضائيه همم
المخالفات التي تصنف اجرائها
من جديد على تربيه دعوتنا هذا المساء في
هذه الرساله الاخباريه المغاربيه
البلاد التونسيه سيد ماهر جديد نائب رئيس
هيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات